i feel your love every day ariana grande
feels love
every day especially on vacay
the 27 year old singer took to instagram
on thursday to share a few pics from her
lover's getaway with her man
dalton gomez ari shared several scenic
shots in the desert
including pics of her shoes and a few
bikini selfies
looking totally relaxed happy and
sunkissed
do you do whatever you want whatever you
want whatever feels natural
and get ready to cue the oz because she
also posted
this sweet black and white snap with her
man
[Music]
what's your favorite part about being in
love every day is
like super exciting just like
waking up and being like hell yeah do
you know what i mean
rumors that ari was dating the luxury
real estate agent
started swirling back in march and she
straight up confirmed it
in the music video for her collab with
justin bieber stuck with you
[Music]
yeah nothing says it's official like a
music video cameo
right
[Music]
in june the lovebirds took it one step
further
making it insta official when the grammy
winner shared these pics from her 27th
birthday
alongside her boo back in may a source
told et
that she and dalton were in a really
good place
as they quarantined together in la amid
the coronavirus pandemic
i'm happy life is good but e.t source
said the pop star
has had some hesitation being so public
about her relationship with dalton
as she's seen how that has worn on her
past relationships it was like so crazy
yeah like her very public engagement to
pete davidson
she's the number one pop star in the
world and i'm that guy from snl
that everyone thinks is in desperate
need of more blood
anyway the whole taking their romance
public thing
doesn't seem to be hurting dalton and
ari's love i'm grateful
in fact he even helped her promote her
new collab with lady gaga
rain on me back in may holding the
shower head to make it rain on
ari in this skit to promote the track oh
we
are thirsty indeed and what the locals
are now saying globally is
rain on me ari also shared this behind
the scenes clip of dalton
literally making it rain on twitter
it'll be raining all summer but we'll
surely be dancing as it does